all right well let's keep the holiday
spirit going CU I'm ready to kick some
butt as you know Jason's new movie
Aquaman in the lost kingdom opens on
December 22nd just in time for Christmas
so in honor of that it's time for
Christmas song addition of sing that
name that tune
[Music]
sing here the host for us everybody give
it up for our very own
Ruben
do
it what's up man nice to meet you
brother all right you ready I'm ready
I'm ready I'm ready I'm ready I'm ready
he seems weak right I can do this I'm
not going to say that he's very big all
right here we go this is similar to the
classic name that tomb game the band
will play a song and Kelly and Jason
will try to guess it the twist is the
game you're going to have to sing the
tune not just say now you get points of
how close you get to the lyrics and for
the enthusiasm of your performance so if
you sang it instead of singing it you
might get some more points all right now
even if you don't get get that first
step up sing your heart out and I might
even still give you a couple of points
okay all right personality all right
let's get things going Kelly is playing
for the left side of the AUD left side
Mak a
noise Jason is playing for the right
side
right
whatever I'm not Aquaman I get it the
winner gets an early Christmas gift and
their side for their side so here we go
y'all ready yes can we step up Sir step
up on the
platform all right all right here we go
Jason y'all take it away
okay
[Music]
oh that's H I didn't even think
get Jason now remember remember if you
know the song you can just jump do
whatever you're hesitant sweet baby
harambe all right here we go Jason I'm
GNA kill you at this next classic
Christmas
song
oh jingle jingle bells jingle yeah
jingle
Belling left side Make some
noise hey can you give me a favor can
you step right here real quick for me
just step right here just step right
there for me cool cool cool I'm G step
up here hey bro you got to sing the song
man like you got to get up here and you
got to sing the song man who get up
there but you got okay all right here we
go you can go back there you go there
you go here we go oh my God here we
go I wonder what it's like to be that
powerful in a room Jason next song
okay
rece
King let every
[Applause]
[Music]
heart
okay from I like it te me be two to one
but that was so much extra it's two to
two all right I'm sorry sorry
Kelly please if you ever Go karaoke and
invite
me I just want to be there okay uhoh
okay it seems like we have time for one
last s who will win this
Aquaman or the American
Idol Jason take it
[Music]
away CHR wish you Merry Christmas and
happy New
[Applause]
Year Merry
Christmas it's a beautiful duet merry
Christmas
everybody I think we did it the same
time I wish
every same time and I almost and I was
and I almost let you win and then he
grabbed my shoulder and I was very
afraid so Aquaman
win
you okay
whatever he's bigger than I am I don't
count everyone is the winner here though
especially us cuz he took his shirt
on Yo audio is The Season's must have
for elevating your outdoor adventure you
throwing it all like magic mic moment um
it offers handsfree communication
between you and another individual up to
2,000 fee that's pretty cool it's
perfect for skiing snowboarding mountain
biking cycling and many more action
adventure sports and you're all going
home with a $300 gift card from Yo
AUD let's hear one more time for Ruben
Irvin
and Jason M everybody so sorry everybody
go see a in the Kingdom it's in theater
starting
[Applause]
[Music]
December thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home